welcome to the stream it is a big night
much-anticipated the Democratic primary
sort of getting underway in earnest and
we have many many things planned for you
this evening
where to start I guess the debate the
debate starts in about 19 minutes we
have let's see if I can I have all sorts
of new shots for you today let's see if
we can test out ah okay this is one of
our options for today where we will have
the large window showing the debate no
audio coming from there right now and
then also something's wrong with the
super chats that's interesting let's see
if I can fix that how is that already
going wrong I just went over all of this
and it was just working so well oh I see
okay let me get that back for you there
we go so we if people like this when the
debate is going on we can have this on
screen if people send super chats they
will pop right up and people have
complained that during the live events
sometimes they they send super chats and
a long time goes by before anything pops
up on screen so this is one possibility
where the super chats will just scroll
through and people will have their
messages seen we've got two people who
just signed up in the last couple of
minutes Jimmy from Philly who
interestingly enough is the big Trump
supporter but also a david pakman show
member is in there
dr. Alicia Wright told us that she is
supporting vice president Joseph Biden
with a $2 Super chat so this is one
possibility and I think that this this
could work I mean this could be this
could be a good thing for us we also
have this other shot which is a just
different sort of configuration you get
a little more of the main window and a
little less of me which a lot of people
will prefer in fact and then we have
also the Super chats in the bottom left
which I could make bigger or smaller I
don't know and then of course at any
time I can just take the debate
fullscreen and you know I've got sushi
coming and a lot of things going on here
so I may want to just step away for
periods of time and then we can just go
fullscreen so a lot of different things
going on I'm sort of leaning towards
this and I see a lot of people this is
shot to as I am calling it seems like a
lot of people in the chat
seem to like that one but we'll see less
David some people are saying debate
fullscreen listen you could just go over
to NBC for that I've got to add I've got
to do some kind of value-added yes of
course there will be audio from the
debate we are going to be listening to
audio from the debate most people saying
shot to hear is shot three if people
like this one you can tell me this is
shot three it feels like the optometrist
two or three two or three these are our
options people seem to be liking shot
number two few people want three three
is now actually surging and people
asking for four three this is getting a
little crazy I actually I genuinely
don't know which one is more popular but
I get the sense that it's number three
so I also I'm gonna be I have my laptop
down below here where I will be taking
notes for tomorrow's show because the
lead story tomorrow will be analysis of
this debate so I will be taking notes
down below I also have paper notes I
wrote on some kind of envelope for what
I'm going to be interested in following
I mean listen number one this is a
primary where particularly tonight's
debate where I want to see what are the
differences the real differences of
opinion and ideas from these candidates
who is going to challenge Elizabeth
Warren from the right of the Democratic
Party and tell her that she's going too
far to the left I'm interested in that
what political disagreements are there
going to be so I will be following that
number two I hope it doesn't get ugly
but I will also be paying attention to
who goes after other candidates not
substantively but personality stuff
attacks of different kind so I'm gonna
be paying attention to that and then
lastly I hope that there is significant
foreign policy discussion and if you
follow me on Twitter which you should be
at de Pakman you will see that I
recently I tweeted about this like 15
minutes ago a lot of these candidates
particularly the ones that are polling
zero and one and two percent or whatever
they have lots of positions particularly
on domestic policy but when it gets to
the rubber meeting the road and they
have to start talking about foreign
policy in some detail it's like deer in
the headlights for a lot of these
candidates now the saving grace for them
is going to be I believe I didn't even
pay attention to exactly what the rules
are for tonight I'm sure they'll tell us
one of the things is that if you only
get a minute to respond and then
30-second rebuttal is I think it might
be that's not a lot of time to really
gaff on foreign policy as long as you
have a talking point or two on each
issue you might be okay so that is
something I will be paying attention to
as well because foreign policy can
separate the wheat from the chaff so to
speak
okay there are a bunch of super chats
coming in and a bunch of new members
people by the way asking about whether I
will open up the phone lines after this
debate that is a question mark it this
is long I mean listen I did the regular
show today I'm gonna I'm gonna whine now
I did the regular show I went downtown
and was interviewed for another show
which I posted a behind-the-scenes
picture of on my Instagram David Pakman
at this other show I did called the
financial diet that I was interviewed in
today they needed to boost me up because
I'm so short in the chair that they had
me in that I was boosted up to such a
degree that my legs were hanging like a
little kid and I posted a
behind-the-scenes picture of that on
David Pakman on Instagram I did that
then I prepped for tomorrow's show and
then now we've got a two and a half hour
livestream so I may take phone calls
I'll tell you this if we get a bunch of
new members and you can use the coupon
code that's right up here to save 40% I
will open up the phone lines and hear
from people and it's been a while I
don't think I've streamed since before
my my vacation which was before Memorial
Day because it has been so hectic with
our air conditioning was down for a
while which made it just way too hot to
do long streams and then I was traveling
and it's good to be back let me put it
that way okay let's see what people are
saying
raagh nut ssbm says what kind of topics
do you think are most likely to cause
major blunders deer-in-the-headlights
moments okay so I think I just addressed
that foreign policy foreign policy you
know most of these candidates
on social issues at least I think
tonight anyway
most of the candidates have been like
pro LGBT rights for at least several
years I think we know who I'm talking
about
and I think on domestic policy there
there will be relatively little gaffe
potential but I think foreign policy is
really the where the the bulk of the
gaffe potential is Anthony Lowe's eggo
with a record we have never had a four
hundred dollar super chat oh and it's
off-screen I'm sorry let me put this up
here there we go
we have never had a four hundred dollar
super chat that I can recall this is a
record-setting super chat from Anthony
Lowe's ago who says I'm curious I am
solid Bernie but I almost think the
nature of the conglomeration of the
Trump may actually be better than a
giant hand in the cookie jar the economy
tanks by shifting democrat so should we
just keep with Trump I'm puking in my
mouth a little but it's getting weird on
the Democratic side what are your
thoughts no no listen it's I don't fully
understand what your concern is I guess
the idea that the economy might the
economy historically does better when it
comes to unemployment and stock market
return at least as far as those two
indicators it does better under
Democratic presidents than Republican so
I don't I don't think I agree with that
Anthony a despite your record-setting ly
generous super chat I think we should
all vote for the person whose positions
most align with ours that's it and if
you're a bernie guy / a trump guy there
is no strategic reason i can think of to
vote for donald trump so please please
don't do that let me just I'm shifting
some papers around here a lot is
happening here today um let's see
Vikram loath says what do you think will
come out of nowhere and jump in the
polls from either night you know I
actually do think that it's possible
andrew yang gets a big boost from
participating tomorrow night because
remember his campaign I don't want to
take credit for Andrew yanks campaign
but I interviewed him in August of 2018
before I think any other equally or
larger channels we're talking to Andrew
yang
and he has slowly built up his donor
base he's still polling like one or two
percent okay I understand that but when
he does appearances they really seem to
be activating people he was on Colbert I
think it was last night or the night
before so I actually do believe that
there is a chance that Andrew yang
really pops after his participation
tomorrow will see number 420 pencil says
Pakman Shapiro 2020 I was not born in
the US and therefore I cannot run
unfortunately or fortunately Brian
Campbell says Warren needs to show she
can be aggressive totally agree
Elizabeth Warren has the right positions
on most issues but her historical debate
performances are up and down they're not
all bad she's just not always the most
it's it's a convent it's not just
aggression it's a combination of
assertiveness and Pythias I would say
that often particularly in debates with
tonight's format are really really
important okay
let's see what else we have here
downfall parodies one says what are your
thoughts on the gender pay gap in
relation to sports should the US Women's
National Team be paid as much as their
male counterparts well I do think that
if you have one sport that makes a lot
more money in total versus another it's
not logical for the athletes in both
sports to be paid the same amount so I
don't I don't think we can just say
every I don't I don't I don't think that
that is a logical way to think about
that but I'd probably have to think
about it as in terms of sports a little
bit more we have a long-form piece on
our website about the gender pay gap the
truth of it and I encourage you to check
it out let's see here
synth wave etc with a nine dollar
99-cent Super chat trying to make sure
these stay on the screen in the right
way see what I can do about that some of
them are kind of going off screen maybe
if I open that up a little bit and then
close it this way are the Super chats
too small for people to read let me know
in the chat
because I can't I mean I'm seeing them
on a large screen so I can't really tell
and see what people are saying here to
small just right
I can read nope I don't know if no means
that they're too small or that they're
too bigger okay it seems like they're
fine okay a synth wave says relatively
new subscriber and love your channel
thank you for the measured and
thoughtful commentary thank you
appreciate it
glad to have you here harsh sparse
hashtag yang gang baby yeah so so far
we've had one Biden supporter send a
super chat and one yang supporter and
now Andrew Newton who sends a $2.00
hashtag Burnie 2020
hashtag burned down for what hashtag
burn baby burn a lot of hash tagging
yeah Andrew Lyne Court is a new YouTube
member Christopher hatch has sent a
super chat
Sabrina Zafar is it harmful for
Democrats that both Liz and Bernie are
running against each other in the
primary YouTube video uploaded last
Friday or over the weekend about that
issue I believe the answer is no not at
this point Sabrina
driven progressive with a $10 super chat
do you think mayor Pete is done for
after that terrible Town Hall no I don't
the Town Hall was a disaster but let me
see here what is going on I haven't
actually looked at how he's doing in
recent polling where is Budaj edge ooh
he he took a big hit in some recent
polls Wow
maybe he is done for I mean listen I
never really thought Buddha judge had
much of a chance to begin with but uh
we'll have to wait and see a little bit
see what the effect is of that Town Hall
Colin Harris with a $5 super chat the
super chats are just flying up the
screen how much will you be talking
during the debate I would like to see
your take on it but I really don't want
to miss anything the candidates say yeah
I'm going to I think that so the last
time we did this I believe that I talked
probably from the comments 20% too much
but when I stopped talking people were
getting a little bit annoyed also that
there was no value being added so I'll
try to chime in
hopefully in ways that don't inter
with my real-time commentary so that you
at least get a sense of how I'm seeing
it all a JH WH Goodell says why do
people hate Hillary Clinton so much
Republicans seem to do much worse on a
monthly basis European asking not even
going to talk about Hillary tonight
Hillary has nothing to do with what's
going on tonight other than the fact
that if she were president this wouldn't
be going on tonight but beyond that she
has nothing to do with tonight's
festivities Jimmy from Philly Trump 2020
it's inevitable the game basement says
if Biden tanks who do you think the
establishment will pick a Buddha judge
or maybe Connell Harris the bread scare
says veggie de 2020
I know that's not how it's pronounced
but that's how I pronounce it John Dan
Delaney will crap the bed that's quite
possible Swamy NASA in a sauna
Ramesh Sachi or Ramesh with a $99 super
chat Tyler Sylvester my favorite news
channel keep up the good work David
thank you
and Isaiah Jeremy Lowe do you believe
any of the Dems could beat Trump
according to the polls many of them
could and I'm excited to see who
ultimately will be facing off against
Donald Trump okay let's make a few
last-minute adjustments here to some of
these shots it looks like I'm not quite
centered in the shots so let me see if I
can take care of that and move myself
into the center
we don't want framing is extremely
important during these live events
imagine if someone tomorrow sees this
channel and says wow what a great stream
except David was slightly off center it
could be the end of the channel okay
let's listen in because we are just four
minutes away oh no they're going to
commercials I don't think we need to
listen to commercials I will mention
again for people asking if and when the
phone lines are going to open the phone
lines may open at the end of this
depending on how tired I am if we get a
bunch of new members signing up at david
pakman.com slash membership I don't care
what you pay all right you can take the
coupon code this is 2020 listed right up
there save 40% pay full price whatever
it is you want to pay if we get a bunch
of new members certainly at minimum ten
that's usually our target but this is
a long long livestream so maybe it
should be something like 15 and we've
got a few actually we're kind of on our
way I want to thank let's see Victoria
King has signed up and William Wiley has
signed up and Braden Leach has signed up
but one person cancelled maybe they were
really offended by that off-center
framing that I just fixed so in any case
we've got three new members I think if
we get 15 during this I I will take some
phone calls once it's all said and done
let's see here who else do we have more
hash tag stuff Wow a little bunch of
these just came in I'm trying to find
the newest one um Dylan hunter oh no now
I'm getting spam we've been having this
crazy problem where I'm getting spam
phone calls through you know I'm not
even going to tell you what the problem
is because I don't want to give people
any ideas in any case we're having a
problem let me put it that way
Dylan hunter says Trump should privatize
air don't give him any ideas hilly bear
or high bear says do you think third way
support hurt warn third way support um
no I don't think it's hurting her in the
in the immediate experience music I am a
writer intern for progressive Colorado
US Senate candidate Stephanie Rose
Spaulding could I email you about having
her on the show you can I mean here's
the thing we have to make a decision
about doing primary interviews because I
want to do them but if we open up that
door we it's a problem because there's
so many pre primary interview requests
and then I'm in I end up picking and
choosing anyway email me but we're
having an internal discussion about that
that issue a Peterson says who is
supporting Joe Biden and why I really
don't understand who he appeals to well
at least one person in our audience who
sent a super chat hi Wade says or
highway Edie thank you and your team for
all you do thank you for watching
Abigail Rangel says my first vote ever
is going to Bernie hashtag Bernie 2020
we've got a retracted super chat a soup
chat from joe romeiro Jordan Faisal eeny
says when this inevitably gets down to a
progressive and Biden who do you think
it will be I don't know the answer to
that I don't know the answer to that but
I hope it's a progressive Akbar Khan
whoop and it just scrolled past I don't
know why that happens but when a bunch
come in at once it just goes crazy why
do people think bernie is more
progressive than yang wouldn't a ubi be
the most progressive policy in the
history of the u.s. if not the world
know that that's not true no new to the
channel loved the Rogen interview we
talked about you bi a lot I don't want
to clog things up with that right now
okay let me pick up the audio because we
are just seconds away let's see what's
going on and keep the super chats coming
which will automatically display on
screen let's take a listen and let me
I've got a million different things
muted NBC News shows text NBC news to
six six eight six six to get the app now
the image of a father and daughter who
drowned while trying to cross the border
from Mexico into the United States has
brought even more attention to the issue
of immigration it's just one of the many
problems facing the country's
immigration system and some argue that
organizations like ice also need to be
abolished completely Jacob Soboroff
breaks down where the candidates stand
on immigration reform okay I don't think
we need this stuff I'm gonna mute it
briefly I saw a couple of people saying
it's a bit loud I'm gonna try to manage
that if it stays too loud let me know
and just it so this is the the last time
I'm going to ask this we have two
options for the shot during the debate
option one is what we have right here
okay but we'll call this number one if
you like this one after I show you both
options please just put a number one in
the chat the other option is this which
is option two I am smaller in the corner
super chats are a little bit bigger and
the main window is a little bit bigger
okay
one or two which one do you prefer this
is one and then this is
you lot of ones in twos all right we're
gonna go with two for the time being and
it looks like we are actually behind
here we go let's take a listen
[Music]
Performing Arts Center
[Applause]
the center and Hall across the country
tonight we're going to take on many of
the most pressing issues at the moment
including immigration the situation
unfolding at our border and the
treatment of migrant children we're
gonna talk about the tensions with Iran
climate change and of course we'll talk
about the economy those kitchen table
issues so many Americans face everyday
some quick rules of the road before we
begin 20 candidates qualified for this
first debate will hear from 10:00
tonight and ten more tomorrow the
breakdown for each was selected at
random the candidates will have 60
seconds to answer and 30 seconds for any
follow-up plenty of times the best large
field not every person will be able to
comment on every topic but over the
course of the next two hours we will
hear from everyone we'd also like to ask
the audience to keep the reactions to a
minimum we are not going to be shy about
making sure the candidates stick to time
tonight all right so with that business
out of the way we want to get to it and
we'll start this evening with senator
Elizabeth Warren senator good evening to
you let's do it you have many plans free
College free child care government
health care cancellation of students new
regulations the breakup of major
corporations but this comes at a time
when 71 percent of Americans say the
economy is doing well including 60
percent of Democrats what do you say to
those who worry this kind of significant
change could be risky to the economy so
I think of it this way who is this
economy really working for it's doing
great
for a thinner and thinner slice at the
top it's doing great for giant drug
companies
it's just not doing great for people who
are trying to get a prescription filled
it's still great for people who want to
invest in private prisons just not for
the African Americans and Latin X whose
families are torn apart whose lives are
destroyed and whose communities are
ruined
it's doing great for giant oil companies
that want to drill everywhere just not
for the rest of us who are watching
climate change bear down upon us when
you've got a government when you've got
an economy that does great for those
with money and isn't doing great for
everyone else that is
shouldn't your and simple we need to
call it out we need to attack it head-on
and we need to make structural change in
our government in our economy and in our
country so who calls her out let's see
which who's going to be but for a sub
beautiful you called programs like free
college something you might do if you
were quote a magic Genie to be blonde
are the government programs and benefits
that some of your rivals are offering
giving your voters and people a false
sense of what's actually achievable well
first the economy we know that not
everyone is sharing in this prosperity
and Donald Trump just sits in the White
House and oh give me a many people that
are having trouble affording college and
having trouble affording their premiums
your pole-zero I do get concerned about
paying for college for rich kids I do
but I think my plan is a good one and my
plan would be to first of all make
Community College free and make sure
that everyone else besides that top
percentile gets help with their
education my own dad and my sister got
their first degrees with Community
College there's many paths to success as
well as certifications secondly I've
used programs I doubled them from 6,000
to 12,000 dollars a year and expand it
to the number of families that get
covered to families that make up to
$100,000 and then the third thing I
would do is make it easier for students
to pay off their student loans because I
can tell you this if billionaires can
try out their yacht students should be
able to pay off their student loans okay
it's unanswered
[Applause]
what we've just been discussing and
talking about is how much fundamental
change to the economy is desirable and
how much is actually doable in that vein
some Democrats want a marginal
individual tax rate of 70 percent on the
very highest earners those making more
than 10 million dollars a year but rates
you support that and if not what would
your top individual rate be this economy
has got to work for everyone and right
now we know that it is and it's gonna
take all of us coming together to make
sure that it does estamos in Cuvier cada
persona en el éxito de este economy a--
pero si quiere Moses arizo necesitamos
in cuy cada persona in Westra democracia
i mean if you're gonna do it you got it
speaking spanish direction y cada vez
necesitamos escuchar right now we have a
system that favors those who can pay for
access and outcomes that's how you
explain an economy that is rigged to
corporations and to the very wealthiest
a two trillion dollar tax cut that
favored corporations while they were
sitting on record piles of cash and the
very wealthiest in this country at a
time of historic wealth inequality a new
democracy that is what because the
people no pacts no gerrymandering
automatic and same-day voter
registration bring in more voters and a
new Voting Rights Act those arrays get
rid of the barriers and replace now
that's how we each have a voice in our
democracy and make this a 70% individual
marginal tax rate yes/no or path I would
support a tax rate and a tax code that
is fair to everyone tax capital at the
same rate that you you tax ordinary
income take that corporate tax rate up
to 28% you would generate the revenues
you need to pay for the programs we're
talking about
hi I'm stunned by what's taking place is
Senator Booker there is a debate in this
party right now about the role of
corporations as you know senator Warren
in particular put out a plan to break up
tech companies like Facebook Amazon and
Google you've said we should not quote
be running around pointing at companies
and breaking them up without
kind of process why do you disagree I
don't think if I disagree I think we
have our serious problem in our country
with corporate consolidation and you see
the evidence of that in how dignity is
being stripped from labor and we have
people that work full-time jobs and
still can't make a living wage we see
that because consumer prices are being
raised by pharmaceutical companies that
often have monopolistic hold on drugs
and you see that by just the fact that
this is actually an economy that's
hurting small businesses and not
allowing them to compete one of the most
aggressive bills in the Senate to deal
with corporate consolidation is mine
about corporate consolidation of the AG
sector so I feel very strongly about the
need to check the corporate
consolidation and let the free market
work and I'll tell you this I live in a
low income black and brown community I
see every single day that this economy
is not working for average Americans the
indicators that are being used from GDP
to Wall Street's rankings is not helping
people in my community it is about time
that we have economy that works for
everybody not just the wealthiest in our
nation the quickly senator Booker you
did say that you didn't think it was
right to name names to name companies
and single them out as senator Warren
has briefly why is that well again I
will single out companies like
Halliburton or Amazon that pay nothing
in taxes and our need to change that and
when it comes to antitrust law what I
will do is number one appoint judges
that will enforce it number to have a
DOJ and a Federal Trade Commission that
will go through the processes necessary
to check this kind of corporate
concentration at the end of the day we
have too much of a problem with
corporate power growing we see that with
everything from citizens united and the
way they're trying to influence
Washington is about time that we have a
president that fights for the people in
this country that time we need to have
someone that's a champion for them Thank
You senator will anyone answer your
question
are you picking winners and losers so
the way I understand this is there is
way too much consolidation now in giant
industries in this country that hurts
workers it hurts small businesses it
hurts
independent farmers it hurts our economy
overall and it helps constrict real
innovation and growth in this economy
now look we've had the laws out there
for a long time to be able to fight back
what's been missing is courage courage
and Washington to take on the Giants
that's part of the corruption in this
system it has been far too long that the
monopolies have been making the campaign
contributions have been funding the
super PACs have been out there making
sure that their influence is heard and
felt in every single decision that gets
made in Washington where I want to start
this is I want to return government to
the people and that means calling out
the names of the monopolist and saying I
have the courage to go after them thank
you I mean I'm doing the best the next
question is for you Democrats have been
talking about the pay gap for decades
what would you do to ensure that women
are paid fairly in this country thank
you very much for that question Lester
you know I grew up with a mother who
raised my brother Joaquin and me as a
single parent and I know what it's like
to struggle I know what it's like to
rent a home and to worry about whether
you're gonna be able to pay the rent
at the 1st of the month and to see a mom
work very very hard and know that moms
across this country are getting paid
less simply because they're women I
would do several things starting with
something we should have done a long
time ago which is to pass the Equal
Rights Amendment
and also pursue legislation so that
women are paid equal pay for equal work
in this country it's past time than we
did that and you know we have to do this
if we want to be the most prosperous
nation in the 21st century we need to
make sure that women are paid what they
deserve all right thank you I wanna put
the same questions your congresswoman
Gabbard your your thoughts on equal pay
well first of all let's recognize the
the situation we're in that the American
people deserve a president who will put
your interests ahead of the rich and
powerful that's not what we have right
now I enlisted in the Army National
Guard after the al Qaeda terror attacks
on 9/11 so I could go after those who
had attacked us on that day I still
serve as a major served over 16 years
deployed twice to the Middle East and in
Congress serve on the Foreign Affairs
and Armed Services committees for over
six years this relate to the question I
know the importance of our national
security
as well as the terribly high cost of war
and for too long our leaders have failed
us taking us from one regime-change war
to the next leading us into a new Cold
War and arms race costing us trillions
of our hard-earned taxpayer dollars and
countless lives this insanity must and
as president I will take your
hard-earned taxpayer dollars and instead
invest those dollars into serving your
needs things like health care a green
economy good-paying jobs protecting our
environment and so much more mayor what
about the intricate offense the mayor of
the biggest city in the United States
but it's also one of the cities in the
country with the greatest gap between
the wealthy and the poor how would you
address income inequality well we've
been dressing income inequality in New
York City by raising wages by raising
benefits by putting money back in the
hands of working people $15 minimum wage
paid sick days pre-k for all things
they're making a huge difference in
working people's lives but let me tell
you what we're hearing here already in
the first round of questions is that
battle for the heart and soul of our
party I want to make it clear this is
supposed to be the party of working
people yes we're supposed to be for 70
percent tax rate on the wealth
yes we're supposed to be for free
college free public college for our
young people we are supposed to break up
big corporations when they're not
serving our democracy okay
this Democratic Party has to be strong
and bold and progressive and in New York
we proven that we can do something very
different we can put money back in the
hands of working people and let me tell
you every time you talk about investing
in people and their communities you hear
folks say there's not enough money what
I say them every single time is there's
plenty of money in this world there's
plenty of money of this country this is
pretty good the wrong hands just saying
stop dancing and tell us you are 40 I
think we need to do real things to help
give no chance for others in the
American people right this is the issue
that all of us here on the campaign
trail we need to make sure everyone has
a living wage and I've called for a
doubling of the Earned Income Tax Credit
raising the minimum wage and creating
payments down will create a situation
where people actually have a living wage
that gets right to workers then we got
to fix our public education system it's
not delivering the results our kids
needs nor is college and post high
school career and technical training
programs doing that you know I'm very
different than everyone else here on the
stage prior to being in Congress I was
an entrepreneur I started two businesses
I created thousands of jobs I spent my
whole career helping small to mid-sized
businesses all over the country 5,000
5,000 of them I supported the Obama
administration gave me an award for
lending to disadvantaged communities I
know how to create jobs we need a
short-term strategy which is to put
money in the pockets of workers with the
Earned Income Tax Credit raising the
minimum wage and created paid family
leave and then we need to have a
long-term strategy to make sure this
country is competitive and we're
creating jobs everywhere in this country
governor Inslee how would you address
income inequality well I'm a little bit
surprised
I think plans are great but I'm a
governor and we got to realize the
people who brought us the weakened
unions need are gonna bring us a long
and I'm proud of standing up for unions
I've got a plan to reinvigorate
collective bargaining so we can increase
wages finally I'm marched with the SEIU
folks it is not right that the CEO of
McDonald's makes two thousand one
hundred times more than the people
singing hash and McDonald's and the next
thing I'll do is put people to work in
the jobs of the present and the future
look at Donald Trump is simply wrong he
says wind turbines cause cancer we know
they caused jobs and we know that we can
put millions of people to work in the
clean energy jobs of the future
carpenters ibw is members machinist were
doing it in my state today and then we
can do what America always does lead the
world in invent the future and put
people at worst so we're gonna do
congressman Ryan Frederick Trump and you
just referred to him promise that
manufacturing jobs were all coming back
to places like your home state of Ohio
can can you make that same promise see
automation but first let's say the
president came he said don't sell your
house to people in Youngstown Ohio and
in his administration just in the last
two years we lost $4,000 at 4,000 jobs
at a General Motors facility that
rippled throughout our community General
Motors got a tax cut General Motors got
a bailout and then they have the
audacity to move a new car that they're
gonna produce to Mexico I've had family
members that have that unbolt a machine
from the factory floor put it in a box
and ship it to China my area where I
come from in Northeast Ohio this issue
we're talking about here it's been going
on 40 years this is not a new phenomenon
in the United States of America the
bottom 60% haven't seen a raise since
1980 meanwhile the top 1% controlled 90
percent of the wealth we need an
industrial policy saying we're gonna
dominate building electric vehicles
there's gonna be 30 million made in the
next ten years I want half of a maybe
United States
I want to dominate the solar industry
thank you manufacture those here
Tim Ryan's actually a good guy I've
interviewed it's basically been like
giant corporations do whatever they want
to do giant corporations have exactly
one loyalty and that is to profits and
if they can save a nickel by moving a
job to Mexico or to Asia or to Canada
they're going to do it right so here's
what I propose for an industrial policy
start with a place where there's a real
need there's going to be a worldwide
need for green technology ways to clean
up the airways to clean up the water and
we can be the ones to provide that we
need to go tenfold in our research and
development on green energy going
forward and then we need to say any
corporation can come and use that
research they can make all kinds of
products from it but they have to be
manufactured right here in the United
States of America and then we have to
double down and sell it around the world
there's a 23 trillion dollar market
coming for green products we should be
the leaders and the owners and we should
have that 1.2 million really try to
understand where there may or may not be
daylight between you many people
watching at home have health insurance
coverage through their employer this is
here would abolish their private health
insurance in favor of a government-run
plan just a show of hands start out with
that's the problem
all right well that isn't the question
do you you're one of the Democrats who
wants to keep private insurance in
addition to a government health care
plan approach in your view better than a
sweeping overall I think it's a bold
approach it's something that Barack
Obama wanted to do when we were working
on the Affordable Care Act and that is a
public option I am just simply concerned
about kicking half of America off of
their health insurance in four years
which is exactly what this question was
beyond that there is a much bigger issue
in addition
and that is pharmaceuticals the
president literally went on TV this is
not significant people's heads would
spin when they see how much he would
bring down pharmaceutical prices instead
2500 drugs have gone up in double digits
since he came into office he said he
gave a hundred billion dollars in
giveaways to the pharma companies for
the rest of us for the rest of America
that's what we call it home all foam and
no beer we got nothing out of it and so
my proposal is to do something about
Pharma to take them on to allow
negotiation under Medicare to bring in
less expensive drugs from other
countries and Pharma thinks they on
Washington
well they don't own their time as that
thank you but health insurance companies
don't want you signed on to Bernie
Sanders Medicare for all plan it would
put essentially everybody on Medicare
and then eliminate private plans that
offer similar coverage is that the plan
or a path that you would pursue as
president so yes I'm with Bernie on
Medicare for all and let me tell you why
I spent a big chunk of my life studying
why families go broke this is the right
one number one reasons is the cost of
health care medical bills and that's not
just for people who don't have insurance
it's for people who have insurance look
at the business model of an insurance
company it's to bring in as many dollars
as they can in premiums and to payout as
few dollars as possible for your health
care
that leaves families with rising
premiums rising co-pays and fighting
with insurance companies to try to get
the health care that their doctors say
that they and their children need
Medicare for all solves that problem and
I understand there are a lot of
politicians who say oh it's just not
possible we just can't do it have a lot
of political reasons for this what
they're really telling you is they just
won't fight for it well health care is a
basic human right and I will fight for
basic
this is the end of maketh bad after not
raising people can you also praised a
bill that would replace private
insurance this year you're saying you're
no longer sure can you explain why my
goal is to ensure that every American is
well enough to live to their full
potential because they had to go back
here in Spanish in Laredo Texas I met a
young man 27 years old told me that he'd
been to a doctor once in his life and on
that visit he was told he had diabetes
he's told he had glaucoma and he was
told untreated because he doesn't have
healthcare he'll be dead before the age
of 40
so getting to guaranteed high quality
universal health care as quickly and
surely as possible has to be our goal
the ability to afford your prescriptions
and go to a primary care provider the
ability to see a mental health care
provider in Texas the single largest
provider of mental health care services
is the County Jail system today and
healthcare also has to mean that every
woman can make her own decisions about
her own body and has access to the care
that makes that possible our plan says
that if you're uninsured we enroll you
in Medicare if you're insufficiently
insured you can't afford your premiums
we enroll you in Medicare but if you're
a member of a union that negotiated for
a health care plan that you like because
it works for you and your family you're
able to keep it we preserve congressmen
but I do want to ask a follow-up on this
one just to be just to be very clear
I'll give you ten seconds would you
replace private insurance no I think the
choice is is fundamental to private
insurance is not working for tens of
millions of Americans when you talk
about oh something is wrong with this
with the feet here let's see just gonna
refresh it oh dear and now we've got an
ad we'll get it back folks we'll get it
back I I wanted to see DeBlasio
absolutely rip them in you want private
health insurance by the way it should be
noted that 100 million Americans I mean
I think we should be the party that
keeps what's working
fixes what's broken I mean doesn't that
make sense I mean we should give
everyone in this country health care as
a basic human right for free . but we
should also give them the option to buy
private insurance why do we have to
stand for taking away something from
people nobody's taking away what you see
you go to every hospital in this country
and you ask them one question which is
how would it have been for you last year
if every one of your bills were paid at
the Medicare rate every single hospital
administrator said they would close and
the Medicare for all bill requires
payments to stay at current Medicare
rates so to some extent we're basically
supporting a bill that will have every
hospital close I mean my dad was a union
electrician right I actually grew up in
a working-class family he loved that
health care that the IBEW gave him and I
just always think about my dad and
anything I would do it from a policy
perspective he'd look at me and he'd say
good job John for getting health care
for every day what are you taking my
home let this play out a little because
it's I'm fascinated to hear the daylight
between you congresswoman Gabbard why
your way in here yes please I think
we're talking about this in the wrong
way you're talking about one bill over
another bill really what we're talking
about is our objective making sure that
every single sick American in this
country is able to get the health care
that they need
I believe Medicare for all is the way to
do that I also think that employers will
recognize how much money will be saved
by supporting a Medicare for all program
a program that will reduce the
administrative costs reduce the
bureaucratic costs and make sure that
everyone gets that quality health care
that they need I also thank you if you
look at other countries in the world who
have universal health care every one of
them has some form of a role of private
insurance I think that's what we've got
to look at taking the best of these
ideas but making sure unequivocally that
no sick American goes without getting
the care that they need regardless at
arms your little money they have in
their pockets
explain to me where you are this is
hugely important to people so tell us
where you are absolutely we'll first of
all we're talking about this is a health
care issue but in communities like mine
low-income communities it's an education
issue because kids don't have health
care are not gonna succeed in school it
is an issue for jobs and employment
because people that do not have good
health care to not succeed at work it's
even a retirement issue because in my
community African Americans have a lower
life expectancy because of poorer health
care and so where I stand is very clear
health care it's not just a human right
it should be an American right and I
believe the best way to get there is
Medicare for all but I have an urgency
about this when I am president the
United States I'm not going to wait we
have to do the things immediately that
are going to provide better care and on
this debate I'm sorry there are too many
people profiteering off of the pain of
people in America from from
pharmaceutical companies to insurers
literally the overhead for insurers that
they charge is 15% while Medicare
overhead is only at 2% we can do this
better in every single day I will be
fighting to give people more access and
more affordable cost until we get to my
goals companies last year alone 23
million dollars in profits out of the
health care system 23 billion dollars
and that doesn't count the money that
was paid to executives the money that
was spent lobbying Washington we have a
giant industry that wants our health
care system to stay the way it is right
it's not working for families but it
sure as heck working families come first
it should not be an option in the United
States of America for any insurance
company to deny woman coverage for their
exercise of their right of choice
only candidate here who has passed a law
protecting a woman's right a
reproductive health and health insurance
and I'm the only candidate who has
passed a public option and I respect
everybody's goals and plans here but we
do have one candidate that's actually
advanced the ball and we got to have
access for everyone I've done it there's
three women up here that have fought
pretty hard for a woman's right to
choose good line not going to get you
above 8% their goal of universal health
care and the idea I put out there the
public option which the governor was
just talking about this idea is that you
use Medicare or Medicaid without any
insurance companies involved you could
do it either way and the estimates are
thirteen million people would see a
reduction in their premiums twelve more
million people would get covered so I
think it is a beginning and the way you
start and the way you move to universal
health care this windows for you all of
you on stage support a woman's right to
an abortion you all support some version
of a government health care option would
your plan cover abortion mr. secretary
yes it would
I don't believe only in reproductive
freedom I believe in reproductive
justice
you know what good lines is that just
because a woman or let's also not forget
someone in the trans community a trans
female is poor doesn't mean they
shouldn't have the right to exercise
that right to choose and so I absolutely
would cover the right to have an
abortion more than that
everybody in this crowd and watching at
home knows that in our country today
a person's right to choose is under
assault in places like Missouri in
Alabama in Georgia I would appoint
judges to the federal bench that
understand the precedent of roe v wade
and will respect it and initially that
make sure that we fight hard as we
transition our health care slot lines to
one where everybody can get and exercise
that right senator Warren would you put
limits on any limits on abortion here we
go
I would make certain that every woman
has access to the full range of
reproductive health care services and
that includes birth control it includes
abortion it includes everything for a
woman it's not enough for us to expect
the courts to protect us 47 years ago
Roe vs. Wade was decided and we've all
looked to the courts all that time and
stayed after wishing he was coming up
this mind Roe has put in exceptions has
come right up to the edge of taking away
protection as a senator we now have an
America where most people support Roe
vs. Wade we need to make that come back
on a discussion we were having about
health and the oeid opioid crisis you
represent a state where fourteen of the
twenty eighth largest pharmaceutical
companies are based should
pharmaceutical companies that
manufacture these drugs be held
criminally liable or what they do they
should absolutely be held criminally
liable because they are liable and
response companies are the individual
before I was running for president I
said I would not take contributions from
pharma companies not take contributions
from corporate packs or Pharma
executives because they are part of this
problem in this opioid addiction in our
country we in cities like mine have been
seeing how we've tried to arrest our way
out of addiction for too long it is time
that we have a national urgency to deal
with this problem and make the solutions
that are working to actually be the law
of our land and make the pharmaceutical
companies are responsible help to pay
for that congressman O'Rourke how would
you deal tonight in this country you
have 2.5 million of our fellow Americans
behind bars it's the largest prison
population on the face of the planet
many are there for nonviolent drug
crimes including possession of marijuana
at a time that more than half the states
have legalized it or decriminalized it a
key thing the residue Pharma has done
their connection to the opioid crisis in
the overdose deaths that we're seeing
throughout this country they've been
able to act with complete impunity and
pay no consequences not a single night
in jail unless there's accountability
and justice this crisis will continue in
my administration we will hold them to
account we will make sure that they pay
a price and we will help those who've
been victims of this malfeasance in this
country get them treatment and long term
care i know immigration is not a lot of
your minds here and i want to talk about
it we're gonna talk about the moment we
need to take a break we'll be back with
more from miami after this okay
which is replete
runners down um actually I'm gonna turn
it down a different way because that's
very loud actually so listen I think
it's abundantly clear so far that
Elizabeth Warren is is crushing this
thing now remember there's there's a
front-runner bias she's also getting
more time I think is important to to
mention but I have to tell you I don't
particularly like the guy and he has no
chance whatsoever but Bill DeBlasio is
on the attack and he is actually calling
things for what they are and I like it
he's got no chance no chance whatsoever
but if you're not going to say all the
right things because you believe all the
right things like Elizabeth Warren go on
the attack and that is exactly what Bill
DeBlasio is doing tons of new members to
thank please keep signing up if you want
the phone lines opened at the conclusion
to what is really working out to be an
extraordinary evening of non answers and
really strange stuff please sign up
coupon code is what direction right over
there saves you 40% Alexander 40 ur has
signed up and can't bury and William
Cramer is a new member
Wendy sherbert love sherbert haven't
it's been a long time since I've had
sherbert actually Thomas Shomo is a new
member
Rajeev Sharma David bit Oh Sandra Joyce
Glen Martin has signed up josue Arellano
Daniel molar Remi Baskin Reb I met Remi
on the streets in Northampton recently
great - uh great to see Remy signing up
that's great
Kathryn Hernandez might have already
mentioned Kathryn it's uh it's a party
all right let's get back to the debate
here whoa
[Music]
turn to an issue that has been in the
news especially this week there are
undocumented children being held alone
in detention yes even as close as
Homestead Florida right here less than
30 miles from where we are tonight
fathers and mothers and children are
dying while trying to enter the United
States of America we saw that image
today that broke our hearts and they had
names all Scott amount of Venus and his
23 month old daughter Val Adia died
trying to cross the river to ask for
asylum in this country last month more
than 130 thousand migrants were
apprehended at the southern border
secretary Castro if you were president
today oh yeah
what would you specifically do say I'm
very proud that in April I became the
first candidate to put forward a
comprehensive immigration plan and we
saw those images watching that image of
Beau Scott and his daughter by Lydia is
heartbreaking
it should also piss us all off if I were
president today
and it should spur us action if I were
president today I would sign an
executive order that would get rid of
Trump's zero-tolerance policy the remain
in Mexico policy and the metering policy
this metering policy is basically what
prompted both Scott in Valletta to make
that risky swim across the river they
have been playing games with people who
are coming and trying to seek asylum at
our ports of entry well Scott in
Valletta went to a port of entry and
then they were denied the ability to
make it asylum claim so they got
frustrated and they tried to cross the
river and they died because of that on
day one they would do that executive
order that would address metering and
then I would follow that up in my first
hundred days with immigration reform
that were onerous island claims that
would put undocumented immigrants as
long as they haven't committed a serious
crime on a pathway to citizenship and
they would go to the root cause of the
issue which is we need a Marshall Plan
for on dudas and wanted mala and inside
the board so that people can find safety
an opportunity at home instead of coming
to the United States to seek it he said
you do on day one and this is a
situation that the next president will
inherit yes the situation our order is
inacceptable
news day Presidente at acabo de Menezes
o los immigrant is inacceptable a voyeur
can be arrested on day one I will make
sure that number one we end the ice
policies and the customs and border
policies are violating the human rights
when people come to their country they
do not leave their human rights at the
border number two I will make sure that
we reinstate daca that we reinstate
pathways to citizenship for daca
recipients and to make sure that people
that are here on temporary protective
status can stay and remain here and then
finally we need to make sure that we
address the issues that made Oscar and
valaria come in the first place by
making major investments in the northern
triangle not like this president is
doing by ripping a way the resources we
need to actually solve this problem we
cannot surrender our values in the thing
we're gonna get border security we
actually will lose security and our
values we must fight for both if I might
very briefly if this is an important
point you know my plan and I'm glad to
see that Senator Booker senator Warren
and governor Inslee agree with me on
this my plan also includes getting read
rid of section 1325 of the Immigration
and Nationality Act to go back to the
way we used to treat this when somebody
comes across the border not to
criminalize desperation to treat that as
a civil violation and here's why it's
important we see all of this horrendous
family separation they used that law
section 1325 to justify under the law
separating little children from their
families so I want to challenge every
single candidate on this stage here we
got a port the repeal of section 39 5
that's actually no my friend here said I
agree with him on that issue but folks
should understand that the separation of
children from families doesn't just go
on at our border it happens in our
community is this ice or ripping away
parents from their American children
spouses and the light and are creating
fear in cities all across this country
where parents are afraid to even drop
their kids off to school or go to work
we must send those policies about in a
great mayor in this country because look
at the bottom line here those tragic
that tragic photo of those have parent
that child and I'm saying this as a
father every American should feel that
in their heart every American should say
that does not America those are not our
values but we have to get under the skin
of why we have this crisis in our system
because we're not being honest about the
division that's been fomented in this
country the way that American citizens
have been told that immigrants somehow
created their misery and their pain and
their challenges for all the American
citizens out there who feel you're
falling behind to feel the American
Dream is not working for you the
immigrants didn't do that to you
[Applause]
heute love it but first we have to tell
working people in America who are
hurting that we're going to be on their
side every single time against those big
corporations who created this mess to
begin with and remind people we're all
in this together if we don't change that
debate that politics that's holding us
back we won't get all these reforms
people are talking about that's what we
need to do as Democrats so we talk to
white people if I could I'm sorry Oh
Clarissa tell Roarke Gary of telling el
primero de su telepathy it's el Cuchillo
what would you do congressman day one at
the White House vamos a tratar de
persona con el respeto y d needed
medicine como uma knows we would not
turn back malaria and her father Oscar
we would accept them into this country
and follow our own Asylum laws we would
not build walls we would not put kids in
cages in fact we would spare no expense
to reunite realize a lot of it have been
separated already congressman you're not
least Asik you live in a family because
you is fleeing the violence a repeal the
first accuser teen 25 you would make
sure moderators have no cannot detain
any family fleeing violence in fact
fleeing the deadliest countries on the
face of the planet today we would
implement a family case management
program so they could be cared for in
the community at a fraction of the cost
and then we would rewrite our
immigration laws in our own image free
dreamers forever from any fear of
deportation by making them US citizens
here in this country invest in solutions
in Central America work with regional
stakeholders so there's no reason to
make that 2,000 mile journey to let's be
very clear the reason that they're
separating these little children from
their families is that they're using
section 1325 of that act which
criminalizes coming across the border to
incarcerate the press the parents and
then separate them some of us on this
stage have called to end that section to
terminate it some like congressman
O'Rourke have not and I want to
challenge all of the can
I just think it's a mistake Beth oh I
think it's a mistake and I think that
that if you truly want to change the
system then we got to repeal that
section if not thank you then it might
as well see America respond to this very
briefly actually as a member of Congress
I helped to introduce legislation that
would ensure that we don't criminalize
those who are seeking asylum and refuge
in this country if you're fleeing if
you're fleeing the desperation island
then I want to make sure with respect
I'm still talking about everybody else
you're looking at just one small part of
this I'm talking about a comprehensive
rewrite of our immigration to folks a
lot of folks that are coming are not
seeking asylum and a lot of them are
undocumented immigrants right and you
said recently that the reason you didn't
want to repeal section 1325 was because
you were concerned about human
trafficking and drug trafficking but let
me tell you what section 18 so I got
title 18 of the u.s. code title 21 and
title 22 already covered we should be
talking about for a long time and we
will for coming here let's let I know
it's just what we could but rather than
talk about specific visions we really
have to talk about why these people are
coming to our country and what are we're
gonna do to actually make a difference
in these countries you'll get your
chance let's continue the discussion
senator klobuchar yeah let's talk about
what secretary Castro just said he wants
to no longer have it be a crime to
illegally cross the border do you
support that do you think it should be a
civil offense only and if so do you
worry about potentially incentivizing
people to come here immigrants they do
not diminish America they are America
and I am happy to look at his proposal
but I do think you want to make sure
that you have provisions in place that
allow you to go after traffickers and
allow you to go after people
who are violating the law what I really
think we need to step back and talk
about is the economic imperative here
and that is that 70 of our fortune 500
companies are headed about by people
that came from other countries 25% of
our us Nobel laureates were born in
other countries we have a situation
right now where we need workers in our
fields and in our factories we need them
to start small businesses we need their
ideas and this president has literally
gone backwards at a time where our
economy needs immigrants and so my
proposal is to look at that 2013 bill
that passed the Senate with Republican
support to upgrade that bill to make it
as good as possible and get it done it
brings the debt down by a hundred fifty
eight billion dollars and it gives a
path to citizenship for citizen for
people who can become citizens and it
was so much better for our economy in
America that's the time Thank You
congressman Ryan same question should it
be obtained gets to illegally crossed
the border or should be a civil offense
only well I agree with secretary Castro
I think there are other provisions in
the law that will allow you to prosecute
people for coming over here if they're
dealing in drugs and other things that's
already established in the law so
there's no need to repeat it and I think
it's a porn we're talking about this
father who got killed with his daughter
and and in the issues here a way these
kids are being treated if you go to
Guantanamo Bay there are terrorists that
are held they get better health care
than those kids that have tried to cross
the border in the United States that
needs to stop and I think the president
should immediately ask doctors and
nurses to go immediately down to the
border and start taking care of these
kids what kind of country are we running
here where we have a president in the
United States who's so focused on hate
and fear and division and what has
happened now the end result is now we've
got kids literally laying in their own
snot with three-week-old diapers that
haven't been changed we've got to tell
this president that is not a sign of
strength
president that is a sign of weakness the
question if you're president on day one
what will you do with the fact that you
will have families here there's been a
lot of talk about what you'll do in the
first 100 days about legislation
what will you actually do with these
families how will you care for them will
they be detained or will they not be
well this is a related and brief point
because what we're talking about what
secretary castro and i are talking about
is that we have the power to better deal
with this problem through the civil
process than the criminal process I have
been to some of the largest private
prisons which are repugnant to me that
people are profiting off in
incarceration and their immigration
lockups our country has made so many
mistakes by criminalizing things whether
it's immigration whether it's mental
illness whether it's addiction we know
that this is not the way to deal with
problems there is a humane way that
affirms human rights and human dignity
and actually solve this problem Donald
Trump isn't solving this problem we've
seen under his leadership a surge at our
border we solve this problem by making
investments in the northern triangle to
stop the reasons why people are being
driven here in the first place and we
make sure we use our resources to
provide health care to affirm the values
and human dignity the people that come
here because we cannot sacrifice our
values our ideals as a nation for border
security we can have both by doing this
the right way what would you do last
Cory Booker I have yet to hear an answer
there anyone I know what we do with the
families that will be here there is no
reason for the detention and separation
of these children they should be
released pending their hearings and they
should have a hearing in the law should
be followed that's what should happen
and we should do what we're doing in
Washington State I'm proud that we've
passed a law that prevents local law
enforcement for being turned into many
ice agents I'm proud to have been the
first governor to stand up against
Donald Trump's heinous Muslim ban I'm
proud to be a person who's not only
talked about dreamers but being one of
the FIR
to make sure that they get a college
education so that they can realize their
dreams these are some of the most
inspirational people in our state and
I'll leave you with this thought what I
think Donald Trump the other died either
day
tried to threaten me he thought it was a
threat to tell me that he would send
refugees in Washington state if we
passed a law that I passed and I told
him that's not a threat at all we
welcomed refugees into our state we
recognized diversity as a strength this
is how we built America that tradition
is going to continually separated from
his family we're going to talk about
Iran right now because we work against
the Klan attack the US drone has been
shown disturbing threats issued by both
the US and Iranian leadership I'd like
if you can't just for a moment to put
aside how you think we may have gotten
here but what I want to know is how do
you dial it back so a show of hands who
as president would sign on to the 2015
nuclear deal as it was originally
negotiated first and foremost it was a
mistake to pull out of that deal and one
of the reasons why we're seeing this
hostility now is because Donald Trump is
marching us to a far more dangerous
situation literally he took us out of
the deal that gave us transparency into
their nuclear program and pushed back a
nuclear breakout 1020 years and now we
see Iran threatening to go further and
who were pulled being pulled and further
and further into this crisis we need to
renegotiate and get back into a deal but
I'm not gonna have a primary platform to
say unilaterally I'm gonna rejoin that
deal because when I impress the United
States I'm gonna do the best I can to
secure this country and that region and
make sure that if I have an opportunity
to leverage a better deal I'm gonna do
it all right senator Klobuchar I'd like
you to answer that question because
you've said you said you wouldn't ago
she ate yourself back into the Iranian
agreement can you argue that that new
nuclear pact as it was ratified was a
good deal yes it was it was imperfect
but it was a good deal for that moment I
would have worked to get longer
sunset periods and that's something we
could negotiate to get back in the deal
but the point is Donald Trump told us
when he got out of it that he was going
to give us a better deal those were his
words and now we are a month away from
the Iranians who claim now that they're
going to blow the caps on enriching
uranium and the Iranians have told us
this and so that's where we are right
now he has made us less safe than we
were when he became president so what I
would do is negotiate us back into that
agreement is stand with our allies and
not give unlimited leverage to China and
Russia which is what he has done and
then finally I would make sure that if
there is any possibility of a conflict
and we're having this debate in Congress
right now that he comes to Congress for
an authorization of military force I
would do that and this president is
literally every single day
ten minutes away from going to war one
tweet away from going to war and I don't
think we should conduct foreign policies
in our bathrobe at 5:00 in the morning
[Applause]
you've said you what you would sign back
on to the 2015 deal would you would you
insist though that it address Iran's
support for Hezbollah let's deal with
the situation where we are where this
president and his chickenhawk cabinet
have led us to the brink of war with
Iran I served in the war in Iraq at the
height of the war in 2005 a war that
took over 4,000 of my brothers and
sisters in uniforms lives the American
people need to understand that this war
with Iran would be far more devastating
far more costly than anything that we
ever saw in Iraq it would take many more
lives that would exacerbate the refugee
crisis and it wouldn't be just contained
within Iran this would turn into a
regional wolf war this is why it's so
important that every one of us every
single American stand up and say no war
with Iran we need to get back into the
Iran nuclear agreement
we need to negotiate how we can improve
it it was an imperfect deal there are
issues like their missile developed
their missile development that needs to
be addressed we can do both
simultaneously to prevent Iran from
developing a nuclear weapon and
preventing us from going there's a very
quick follow-up well what would you
redline be that would that for military
action against Iran look obviously if
there was an attack against the American
our troops then there would have to be a
response but my point is and it's
important for us to recognize this is
Donald Trump and his cabinet Mike Pompeo
John Bolton and others are creating a
situation that justice spark would light
off a war with Iran which is incredibly
dangerous that's why we need to
deescalate tensions Trump needs to get
back into the Iran nuclear deal and
swallow his pride put the American
people first continuing next with Chuck
Todd Rachel Maddow's stick around we'll
have a lot more with some very anxious
candidates just yeah
[Music]
okay so listen if I had to say who is
doing best so far it would be
interestingly it would be number one
Elizabeth Warren number two I think it's
the Blasio I'm not saying the guys got a
shot I'm not saying I'd vote for him or
anything of the sort but he's actually
playing the game the right way if you
are a lesser known candidate some of
these other people are you will not
remember a single thing they said
tomorrow some of these others zero one
and two percenters de Blasio is at least
trying to play a role here right and
then I think that Castro is benefiting
significantly from immigration being in
the news because he actually does know a
lot about that issue and he can speak to
it with specificity and he was able to
put better o'rourke sort of on the
defensive on that issue so that would be
my order so far Warren who's been quiet
for a while and is going to need to get
back into it if she wants to if you if
you know Daniel Kahneman's work you know
about peak and bias and even if she did
well early she's going to need to get
something near the end because that's
going to be more present in people's
minds when they you know it's a two-hour
debate what do you retain from it I
think Warren de Blasio and Castro are
the three that are doing the best so far
let me know via super chat if you
disagree we have a ton of new members to
thank who have used this coupon code
over here this is 2020 which is an
extraordinarily exciting thing David
Reutimann
and wail on Pfeiffer Dennis Hawley
Brandon Delgado Brandon Gianotti Josh
Thompson has just signed up I hope I'm
pronouncing this correctly dia or dick
disha Johnson John Carr has signed up
Julie Porter is a new member Brian Holt
has signed up John Crowes Chris Mannion
James Neal I might have thanked before
maybe not near a Ryan
Neera rain rather near a rain Domingo -
salute - Louie I don't think I'm
pronouncing that correctly Alex Rivera
and Yael or jail few cigar few Sager who
sagar a lot a lot of difficult ones
today so please
continue to support the stream we have
by the way I'm getting text messages
that we have more than twice the number
of live viewers currently as The Young
Turks which could be completely untrue
and even if true is of only arbitrary
and very fleeting meaning and value but
it is interesting nonetheless and I am
likely going to be doing another stream
tour tomorrow night the more new members
we get today the more likely it is that
we do a stream tomorrow night and then
much more likely we will do I could
potentially even start earlier tomorrow
and maybe take phone calls after for a
while so let's uh let's keep it all
happening we are going to have new
moderators coming up after the break and
same candidates for better or worse some
people are ready to see other candidates
super chats continue to come in mr. rag
dollar says hey Pac Man loved the show
a bunch of new YouTube members Paul
Tribble wits says keep up the great work
Eve Bouvier with a dollar super chat the
Eastern Shore leftist sent in two
dollars Ryan Brinks wondering something
many of us are wondering why is John
Delaney even here Noah polt Noah
Paulding says proud of you David keep up
your sincere work ray Cromwell why are
they spending so much time on
immigration playing right into the right
wing which wants to keep their this
wedge issue distraction front and center
yeah I mean it's because it's so much in
the news and as I said Castro very
strong on immigration significantly more
so than other candidates other than
maybe Beto who actually is not is not
bad on immigration Josef Davenport thank
you for becoming a new member let's get
back to the second hour of this eventful
and also uneventful in some ways I'll
debate
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome first Democratic presidential
debate from the our Center in Miami and
as we continue the questioning time to
get more members of our team in the mid
so right now let's turn it over to Chuck
Todd and Rachel matter
take it away here we go
[Applause]
twenty candidates qualified for this
first democratic debate we're gonna hear
from ten tonight ten more tomorrow the
breakdown for each night was selected at
random now the candidates will have 60
seconds to answer 30 seconds for a
follow-up if necessary and we will be
ruthless if necessary and we've got a
lot of ground to cover we're gonna be
talking about guns and climate here up
top a whole lot more in this hour
obviously because of the size of the
field not every person will be able to
weigh in on everything but over the
course of this next hour we will hear
from everyone
I promise everybody at least to begin
with we're gonna go with guns and
Senator Warren I want to start with you
we are less than 50 miles from parkland
Florida where 70 people were killed in a
school shooting last year and where
there has been significant activism on
gun violence ever since many of you are
calling for a restoration of an assault
weapons ban
but even if implemented there will still
be five dozen millions I've done to this
country's been talking in the back there
be a role for the federal government
some mics are on everybody's mics are on
I think we have a I heard that too
that's okay I think we had a little mic
issue in the back control room we've got
we have the
yeah we have the audience are you now
right so the question is simply this we
talk we're from I apologize you guys
didn't get to hear this the first part
of the question obviously we're not far
from parkland Florida gun activism has
become a big part of high school life up
there in Broward County many of you are
calling for tighter gun restrictions
some of you calling for the restoration
of the assault weapons ban but even if
it's put in place are still going to be
perhaps hundreds of millions of guns
still on the streets is there a role for
the federal government in order to play
in order to get these guns off the
streets there's the whole conversation
happening in addition to the debate we
are hearing our colleagues audio if the
controllers can turn off the mics of our
previous moderators we will guess what
guys we are gonna take a quick break
we're gonna get this technical situation
fixed we will be right back yes
what will this is going swimmingly for
whoever the audio engineer is this
evening and a lot of people immediately
immediately calling for impeachment of
that of that individual okay I'm
actually interested in hearing whether
there are any substantive differences on
guns sometimes Democratic candidates
will try to distinguish themselves from
others in a sort of play to the pro-gun
right by sometimes
paying lip service to and sometimes
genuinely having more pro-gun
perspectives and I'm curious to see what
we are going to hear there Scott Johnson
sending in a super tech you're ten times
better than TYT get over your TDS I
guess they mean Trump derangement
syndrome I will take that under
advisement
thanks to Jared Hudson who has just
signed up for a membership on our
website thanks to Magnus Bergson who has
a new member
Bryson Bernard and also Jeffrey Arnold
and Robert brooder our new patrons at
patreon.com slash David Pakman show
along with Rini hara who has signed up
we keep all but two percent of
membership payments on our website
making it the most efficient way to get
money to a super chats we keep 70
percent patreon we keep 95 percent a
website memberships we keep 98 percent
because we own the entire system and it
is a really great way to support the
work that we do 6500 people currently
watching this live stream we estimate
only 1% of our audience actually
supports the show financially that would
be 65 people 65 have not signed up so
far that would be a nice initial target
and by the way if we can get to 2% which
would be a hundred and thirty of the
people currently watching we would be in
really really great shape so thanks to
everybody who is already supporting
night one of debate one for the
Democratic primary Elizabeth Warren I
believe is doing the best followed by
Bill DeBlasio this is not my opinion as
to who I would vote for it's not my
opinion as to whose policies I most
agree with I'm merely saying who I think
is doing the best tonight and I believe
it is Elizabeth Warren although she's
got to get back into it it's been
while since she talked bill de blasio is
calling people out when they are playing
coy with what their political positions
are he is saying hey we are if we are
progressives and not everybody on the
stages we should support progressive
policies yes it means all of the
different things that he's talking about
and then specifically because
immigration has been such an issue I
believe that Julian Castro has done
really well tonight although I don't
think he has any shot and I think on a
lot of other issues he's not
particularly strong he has definitely
benefited today from immigration being a
big topic
Quinn --ax yeah she AMA says if Tulsi is
president I'm calling her Wonder Woman I
don't think you're gonna have to worry
about that based on the polls but that
may change Terrell Bradshaw with a $5
Super chat just want to help out and
then Daniel Henson who says surprised by
de Blasio and Castro Warren is still the
only realistic candidate on the stage
tonight I'm very disappointed that she
isn't in tomorrow's group yeah I her
before this debate I said it could be
good for Warren to be a night one it
could be not as good because she won't
be up there with the other frontrunner
she did really well in that first hour
but if people remember what's most
recent in the end there is going to be
two hours of debate tomorrow where she
won't even be on the stage and is that
going to push her sort of further back
in people's memories I think that that's
a very reasonable question thanks to
Brad O'Connor who has just signed up for
a membership as well as Solomon
carpenter were apparently 10 seconds
from being back to the debate so let's
pick up the audio once again and see
what's going on here if they got this
audio problem
[Music]
[Applause]
we believe we have the technical
difficulties never say that never say
never but we will we will march forward
here and I will lean forward here a
little bit senator Warren we're gonna
get to the gun question here parkland
Florida it's just north they here in
Broward County as you know it has
created a lot of teenage activism on the
gun issue it has inspired a lot of you
to come out with more robust plans to
deal with guns including assault weapons
ban but even if you're able to implement
that what do you do about the hundreds
of millions of guns already out there
and as a federal government have to play
a role in dealing with it so in this
period of time that I've been running
for president I've had more than a
hundred town halls I've taken more than
two thousand unfiltered questions and
the single hardest question I've gotten
I got one from a little boy and I got
one from a little girl and that is to
say when you're president how are you
going to keep us safe that's our
responsibility as adults seven children
will die today from gun violence
children and teenagers and they won't
just die in mass shootings
they'll die on sidewalks they'll die in
playgrounds they'll die in people's
backyards gun violence is a national
health emergency in this country and we
need to treat
we can do the things that are sensible
we can do the universal background
checks we can ban the weapons of war but
we can also double down on the research
and find out what really works where it
is that we can make the differences at
the margins that will keep our children
safe
research is killing our children
you didn't address you do you think the
federal government needs to go and
figure out a way to get the guns that's
already out there what I think we need
to do is we need to treat it like a
serious research problem which we have
not yet would rather skin under answer
guns in the hands of a collector who's
had them for decades who's never fired
them who takes safety seriously that's
very different from guns that are sold
and turned over quickly we can't treat
this is it across the board problem we
have to treat it like a public health
emergency
that means bring data to bear and it
means make real change in this country
thank you whether it's politically
popular or not senator Booker you have a
program you have a federal government
buyback program in your plan how is that
gonna work well first of all I want to
say my colleague and I both have been
hearing this on the campaign trail
well what's even worse is I hear
gunshots in my neighborhood I think I'm
the only one I hope I'm the only one on
this panel here that had seven people
shot in their neighborhood just last
week someone I knew shahad Smith was
killed with an assault rifle at the top
of my block last year for millions of
Americans this is not a policy issue
this is an urgency and for those who
have not been directly affected they're
tired of living in a country where their
kids go to school to learn about reading
writing and arithmetic and how to deal
with an active shooter in their school
this is something that I'm tired of and
I'm tired of hearing people all they
have to offer us
thoughts and prayers in my faith
say faith without works is dead so we
will find a way but the reason we have a
problem right now is we've let the the
corporate gun lobby frame this debate it
is time that we have bold actions and a
bold agenda I will get that done as
president United States because this is
not about policy this is personal Thank
You senator Booker just mentioned there
the idea of active shooter drills in
schools the school shooting seemed like
and almost every day or every week
occurrence now they don't make a
complete news cycle anymore no matter
the death toll as parents are so afraid
as their kids go off to school that
their kids will be caught up in
something like this next to nothing has
changed in federal law that might affect
the prevalence of school shootings is
this a problem that is going to continue
to get worse over our lifetimes or is
there something that you would do as
president that you really think would
turn it around yeah Rachel I the dad of
a ten-year-old girl Kadena who's here
tonight and the worst thing is knowing
that your child might be worried about
what could happen at school a place
that's supposed to be safe the answer
your question is no we don't have to
accept that and I believe that on
January 20th 2021 at 12:01 p.m. we're
going to have a Democratic president a
Democratic House and a Democratic Senate
the activists of parkland folks from
moms demand who have risen risen up
across the United States and inspired so
many people you know we may not have
seen yet
legislative action but we're getting
closer the house took a vote in the
Senate the question often is if it's if
the decision is between 60 votes a
filibuster or passing common-sense gun
reform
I'm gonna choose common sense gun reform
so I believe that we're gonna be able to
get that done in 2021 briefly clear
follow up on that question on that
answer from secretary Castro congressman
Ryan you're talking about in the schools
these kids are traumatized I support all
the gun reforms here we need to start
dealing with the trauma that our kids
have we need trauma based care in every
school we need social and emotional
learning in every school 90% of the
shooters whose view school shootings
come from the school they're in and 73%
of them feel shamed traumatized or
bullied we need to make sure that these
kids feel connected to the school that
means a mental health counselor in every
single school in the United States we
need to start playing offense or if our
kids are so traumatized that they're
getting a gun and going into our schools
we're doing something wrong - and we
need reform around trauma
- O'Rourke you're a Texan is campaign
you can't paint all over the state in
2018 and the most conservative parts
there what do you tell a gun owner who's
may agree with you on everything else
okay but says you know what the
Democrats if I vote for him in there
they're gonna take my gun away and even
though I agree with you only these other
issues I guess how do you have that
conversation here's how we had that
conversation in Texas I shared with them
what I learned from those students who
survived the Santa Fe High School
shooting young student named Bree her
friend Marcel who survived another
shooting the mother of a victim who lost
her life Rhonda Hart they talked about
universal background checks where you
close every loophole we know that they
save lives talked about ending the sales
of assault weapons into our communities
those what
of war were designed to kill people as
effectively and as efficiently as
possible they should belong on the
battlefield and not in our communities
red flag laws so that if someone poses a
danger to themselves or to someone else
they're stopped before it's too late and
what I found in each one of those 254
counties is it Democrats and
independents and Republicans gun owners
and non-gun owners alike agreed but this
effort must be led by the young people
that you referenced at the beginning of
this issue those students from Marjory
Stoneman Douglas led the charge here in
Florida and they've been able to change
those laws they're making our democracy
work ensuring that our values and our
interests and our priorities are
reflected in the laws that we pass let
me let me give 30 seconds senator
Klobuchar the Iron Range I'm curious gun
confiscation right if the government is
buying back how do you how do you not
have that conversation
confiscation you give them the offer to
buy back their gun but I'll say this
I don't proposals and I say does this
hurt my Uncle Vic and his deer stand
coming from a proud hunting and fishing
state these proposals don't do that when
I was a prosecutor I supported the
assault weapon ban when I was in the
Senate I saw those moms from Sandy Hook
come and try to advocate for change and
we all failed and then now these park
Lincoln's from Florida they started a
literally and national shift you know
why it's just like with gay marriage
when kids talk to their parents and
their grandparents they say I don't
understand why we can't put these
sensible things in place they listen and
if we get bested by a bunch of 17
year-olds it's the best thing
senator Mitch McConnell says that his
most consequential achievement as Senate
Majority Leader was preventing President
Obama from filling a Supreme Court seat
having served with Republicans on the
Judiciary Committee do you believe they
would confirm your court nominees
I'm gonna use 25 seconds just to say
there's one thing we don't all agree
with when it comes to guns and I think
it's common sense and over 70% of
Americans agree with me if you need a
license to drive a car you should be the
license to buy and own a firearm and not
everybody in this field agrees with that
but it states like Connecticut that did
that they saw 40% drops in gun violence
and 15% drops in suicides we need to
start having bold agendas on guns when
it comes to the Supreme Court very
clearly we I agree with my friend
secretary 9fi geek are you all right 250
votes confused about that this is a team
sport whoever is our nominee needs the
campaign in places like South Carolina
because we can elect Jamie Harrison they
need to examine places like Iowa because
we we can win a Senate seat there this
is about getting us back to have oh dear
being 50 votes in the Senate and more so
that we can not only balance the Supreme
Court but start to pass an aggressive
agenda that frankly isn't so aggressive
because most of America agrees with the
policy objectives of our party
you'll have some the latest equipment
mayor de Blasio is an executive in the
largest city and has a grand story you
are used to saying what you want to have
happen and having it happen if you
nominate a Supreme Court nominee as
president of the United States and mitch
mcconnell's still Senate Majority Leader
what makes you believe that he would
allow you to make a nominee Rachel I am
chief executive the nation's largest
city and I also want to just say
something quick on the gun issue and
come to your question look I run the
largest police force in America - and if
we're going to stop these shootings we
won't get these guns off the street we
have to have a very different
relationship between our police and our
community I also want to say there's
something that sets me apart from all my
colleagues running in this race that is
for the last 21 years I've been raising
a black son in America and I have had to
have very very serious talks with my son
Dante about how to protect himself on
the streets of our city in all over this
country including how to deal with the
fact that he has to take special caution
because there been too many tragedies
between our young men and our police -
as we saw recently in Indiana so we need
to have a different conversation in this
country about guns but also a different
conversation about policing that brings
police and community together we've done
that in New York City and we've driven
down crime while we've done it but to
your question about Mitch McConnell
there's a political solution that we
have to come to grips with it the
Democratic Party would stop acting like
the party of the elites and be the party
of working people again and go into
states including red states to convince
people we're on their side we can put
pressure on their senators to actually
have to vote for the nominees that are
put forward decent Joris lovely okay and
what did you like
so I'm gonna get you I will get you 30
seconds I promise let me get let me get
this question we're trying I know you
guys we got other issues we're trying to
get to including a big one coming up in
a minute but Senator Warren I want to
continue on the Mitch McConnell thing
because you have a lot of ambitious
plans you have a plan for that
okay we talked about the Supreme Court
do you have a plan to deal with Mitch
McConnell if you don't beat him in the
Senate if he's still sitting there as
the Senate Majority Leader it's very
plausible you be getting elected
president with a Republican Senate do
you have a plan to deal with Mitch
McConnell I do
we are democracy and the way of
democracy is supposed to work is the
will of the people matters now we for
far too long have had a Congress in
Washington that is just completely
dismissed what people care about across
this country they have made this country
work much better for those who can make
giant contributions made it work better
for those who hire armies of lobbyists
and lawyers and not made it work for the
people well here's how I see this
happening number one sure I want to see
the Democratic majority in the Senate
but short of the Democratic majority in
the Senate you better understand the
fight still goes on
it starts in the White House and it
means that everybody we energize
in 2020 stays on the front lines come
January 2021 we have to push from the
outside have leadership from the inside
and make this Congress reflect the will
I'm gonna get to people I'm gonna get a
couple of you in here I'm gonna give you
a couple in here thirty seconds not her
stronger than Delaney you seem to
believe you can do everything in a
bipartisan manner Mitch McConnell
doesn't operate that way he operates
differently why do you think he is going
to conform to your style we need to get
things done that's why I believe we need
to operate in a bipartisan manner
listen I'll sign into law pills that
come to the White House that are passed
on a party line basis absolutely but all
the big transformative things we've ever
done in this country's history have
happened when huge majorities of the
American people get behind them which is
why we need real solutions not
impossible promises we need to put forth
ideas of work whether it's on health
care
creating universal health care so that
every American's health care but not
running on making private insurance
illegal the gun issue is related the gun
safety issue is related because I can't
tell you how many times I've been with
folks in Western Maryland and they've
said to me you know Democrats don't do
anything for us Republicans don't do
anything for us you fight all the time
so they vote on that single issue okay
we become the party of
things done and for the American people
a real soldier senator Booker 30 seconds
you how do you deal with myths Mitchell
you've been in the Senate you can't get
bills on the floor right now with Mitch
McConnell presidents can't do it his
president Booker gonna get his bills on
the floor with Senator McConnell you
know when I got to the United States
Senate going back to what de Blasio said
as an African American man in an African
American dominated community you knew he
was my biggest issue police
accountability to dealing with the fact
that we have a nation that has more
African Americans under criminal
supervision than all the slaves in 1850
and when I got to the Senate people told
me we could not get a comprehensive
criminal justice reform bill done as my
colleagues in the Senate know I fought
on that bill from the day I got to the
Senate build coalitions across the aisle
and today we passed the first step act
it's not as far as I want to go but
thousands of people you'll be liberated
I have gotten I've taken on tough
problems people said we cannot achieve
and I've been able to get things
accomplished thank you senator Booker
Rachel's got the next question you're
gonna be happy with where we go governor
Inslee that's the second is to you you
got me
you have staked your candidacy on the
issue of climate change it is first
second and third priority for you you
said it's all the issues let's get
specific please we're here in Miami
which is already experiencing serious
flooding on sunny days as a result of
sea level rise parts of Miami Beach and
the keys could be underwater in our
lifetimes does your plan save Miami yes
first by taking away the filibuster from
Mitch McConnell to start with we have to
do that we'll get press via the first
generation to feel the sting of climate
change and we are the last that can do
something about it our towns are burning
our fields are flooding Miami's is
inundated and we have to understand this
is a climate crisis and emergency and it
is our last chance in the administration
next one to do something about it and we
need to do what I've done in my state
we've passed a 100% clean electrical
grid bill we now have a vision statement
and my plan has been called the gold
standard of putting people to work but
the most important thing on this in the
biggest decision for the American public
is who's gonna make this the first
priority and I am the candidate in the
only one who's saying this has to be the
top priority of the United States the
organizing principle to also put out a
big climate change plan from your short
period of time including switching to
renewable energy pushing to replace
gas-powered cars in favor of electric
ones what's your message to a voter who
supports the overall goal of what you're
trying to do but suddenly feels as if
government's telling them how to live
and ordering them how to live what is
that balance like I think you've got to
bring everybody in to the decisions and
the solutions to the challenges that we
face that's why we're traveling
everywhere listening to everyone we were
in Pacific junction a town that had
never meaningly flooded before just up
against the Missouri River in Iowa and
every home in that community had flooded
there were farms just outside a Pacific
junction that were effectively lakes
those farmers already
underwater in debt their markets closed
to them by a trade war under this
administration and now they don't know
what to do we in our administration are
gonna fund resiliency in those
communities in Miami in Houston Texas
those places that on the front lines of
climate change today we're gonna
mobilize five trillion dollars in this
economy over the next 10 years we're
gonna free ourselves from a dependence
on fossil fuels and we're gonna put
farmers and ranchers in the driver's
seat renewable and in sustainable
agriculture to make sure that we capture
more carbon out of the air and keep more
of it in the soil paying farmers for the
environmental services that they want to
provide if all of us does all that we
can then we're gonna be able to keep
this planet from warming another two
degrees Celsius and ensure that we match
what this country can do and live up to
our promise and our potential 32nd
secretary Castro yeah does who pays for
the mitigation to climate whether it's
building sea walls for people that are
perhaps living in places that they
shouldn't be living is this a federal
government issue that needs to do that
do they have to move these people what
do you do about that where maybe they're
they're building a house some intimate
space to build that who's curious and
how much should the government be
bailing them out well I don't think that
that represents the vast majority of the
issue in fact you know my first visit
after I announced my candidacy wasn't to
Iowa or New Hampshire it was to San Juan
Puerto Rico because people should know
that
elected president everybody will count
and you know I'm one of the few
candidates in this race with executive
experience yeah there's another record
of getting things done when I was mayor
of San Antonio we moved our local public
utility we began to shift it from
coal-fired plants to solar and other
renewables and also created more than
800 jobs doing that and when I was HUD
secretary we worked on the National
Disaster resilience competition to
invest in communities that we're trying
to rebuild from natural disasters in a
sustainable way okay that's the way that
we're gonna help make sure that we're
all safer in the years to come and that
we combat climate change
if I'm elected president the first thing
that I would do right like senator
Klobuchar olenka said is sign an
executive nono get a border recommitting
us to the Paris climate Accord so that
we got a full question for you here
which is simply that you're there are a
lot of the climate plans include pricing
carbon taxing carbon in some way this
type of proposal has been tried in a few
places whether it's Washington State
where voters voted it down you've had
the yellow vest movement we had in
Australia one party get rejected out of
fear of the cost of climate change sort
of being put on the backs of the
consumer if pricing carbon is just
politically impossible how do we pay for
climate mitigation well there's a
variety of different ways to pay we talk
about different ways of raising revenue
and I think we've got to build our way
out of this and grow our way out of it
but let me just talk real quick to the
previous question about real politics we
could talk about climate we could talk
about guns we could talk about all of
these issues that we all care about we
have a perception problem with the
Democratic Party we are not connecting
to the working-class people in the very
states that I represent in Ohio and the
industrial Midwest
we've lost all connection that we have
got to change the center of gravity of
the Democratic Party from being coastal
and illegal ëletís and Ivy League which
is the perception to somebody from the
Forgotten communities that have been
left behind for the last thirty years to
get those workers back on our side
we can say we're gonna build electric
vehicles we're gonna build solar panels
but if you want to beat Mitch McConnell
this better be a working-class party if
you want to go into Kentucky and take
his rear end out and if you want to take
Lindsey Graham out you got to have a
blue-collar party that can go into the
textile communities in South Carolina if
we don't address that fundamental
problem with our connection to workers
white black brown gay straight
working-class people comes none of this
is going to get done Chuck Chuck thank
you very much all the economists agree
that a carbon pricing mechanism works
you just have to do it right you can't
put a price on carbon raise energy
prices and not give the money back to
the American people my proposal which is
put a price on carbon
give it dividend back to the American
people it goes out one pocket back in
the other thank you guys can't get that
past my first year as president with a
coalition of every Democrat in the
Congress and the Republicans who live in
coastal states thanks for poverty our
way forward if we're actually serious
about this issue congresswoman Gabbard
move here one of the first things you
did after launching your campaign was to
issue an apology to the LGBTQ community
about your past stances and statements
on gay rights after the Trump
administration's rollbacks of civil
rights protections for many in that
community why should voters in that
community or voters that care about this
issue in general trust you now let me
say that there is no one in our
government at any level who has the
right to tell any American who they
should be allowed to love or who they
should be allowed to marry my good
series shows my commitment to fighting
for LGBTQ equality I serve on the
Equality caucus and recently voted for
passage of the Equality Act
be many people in this country can
relate to the fact that I grew up in a
socially conservative home held views
when I was very young that I no longer
hold today I've served with LGBTQ
service members both in training and
deployed downrange I know that they
would give their life for me and I would
give my life for them
it is this commitment that I'll carry
through as president of the United
States recognizing that there are still
people who are facing discrimination in
the workplace still people were unable
to find a home for their families it is
this kind of discrimination that we need
to address but it's not enough thank you
Sommers if I can add to this effort it's
very good 30 seconds not enough look
civil rights is some place to begin but
in the african-american civil rights
community another place to focus almost
to stop the lynching of African
Americans we do not talk enough about
trans Americans especially
african-american trans Americans and the
incredibly high rates of murder right
now we don't talk enough about how many
children about 30% of LGBTQ kids who do
not go to school because of fear it's
not enough just to be on the Equality
Act I'm an original co-sponsor we need
to have a president that will fight to
protect LGBTQ Americans every single day
from violence Thank You senator Booker
you have civil rights for decades on the
issue of civil rights and demographics
Asli and politics for decades the
Democratic Party has counted on African
American voter turnout as step one to
winning elections on a national level
Democrats are counting on the Latino
community now and in the future in the
same way what have you done for black
and Latino voters that should enthuse
them about going to the polls for you as
nominee my life and my career and my
work in the Senate has been about
Economic Opportunity and to me this
means better childcare for everyone in
this country and when you want to have
economy that works
you need to have retirement that works
you need to have public schools that
work and you also need to make sure that
that those communities are able to get
those jobs of the future the STEM jobs
in fact Donald Trump one of the first
bills that he's signed of the 34 he
signed where I was the lead Democrat
okay that's a first up here was one that
was about that making sure minority
community members could share in those
jobs so to me this is about a few things
it's about an african-american woman
that goes to a hospital in New Orleans
says her hands are swollen and then
doctor ignores her and her baby dies
it's about the fact that
african-american women make 61 cents for
every dollar a white man makes so in
short we need to one and I will do this
in my first 100 days as president we
will work to make sure everyone can vote
at this table everyone can vote in this
country that's how we will also go to
the next step of criminal justice reform
senator Booker and I worked on that
first step back but we should go to the
second step back which is to help all
our communities our senators thank you
very much 30 second follow-up to you
secretary Castro this is a 70% Latino
City here in Miami you are the only
Latino Democrat who is running this year
in the presidential race
some people like weekdays
economic justice agenda is that enough
to mobilize Latino voters to stand with
the Democratic Party in a big way well I
also think that we have to recognize
racial and social justice and you know I
was in Charleston not too long ago and I
remembered that Dylan roof went to the
mother Emanuel AME Church and he
murdered nine people who were
worshipping in them he was apprehended
by police without incident well but what
about Eric garner and Tamir rice and
laQuan McDonald and Sandra bland and
Pamela Turner and I'm Tony odyssic I'm
proud that I'm the only candidate so far
that has put forward legislation that
would reform our policing system in
America and make sure that no matter
what the color of your skin is that
you're treated the same including
Latinos who were mistreated too
oftentimes by police
secretary Castro thank you let me go
over to Lester Holt who's got a question
I believe a question I'm over here Chuck
thanks we asked voters from across the
country to submit their questions the
candidates will be read one now this
comes from John in New York letting go
submitted this question he asks does the
United States have a responsibility to
protect in the case of genocide or
crimes against humanity do we have a
responsibility to intervene to protect
people threatened by their governments
even when atrocities do not affect
America's war interest in Pollock I'd
like to direct that question to
congressman or work John I appreciate
the the question the answer is yes but
that action should always be undertaken
with allies and partners and friends
when the United States presents a united
front we have a much better chance of
achieving our foreign policy aims and
preventing the kind of genocide to which
you refer the kind of genocide that we
saw in Rwanda the kind of genocide we
want to stop going forward but
unfortunately under this administration
President Trump has alienated our allies
and our friends and our alliances he's
diminished our standing in the world and
he's made us weaker as a country less
able to confront challenges whether it's
Iran or North Korea yeah not the cloud
Amir Putin in Russia who attacked and
invaded our democracy in 2016 and who
president Trump has offered another
invitation to
the same he's embraced strong men in
dictators at the expense of the great
democracies as president I will make
sure that we live our values in our
foreign policy I will ensure that we
strengthen those alliances and
partnerships and friendships right but
when you classically face data together
that makes America stronger what about
the War Powers Act being a part of that
equation with deep respect to the
congressman look we've learned of
painful lessons as Americans that we've
gone to war without congressional
authorization and look this is very
personal for me I know the cost of war
my dad served in the Pacific in World
War two in the US Army
Battle of Okinawa had half his leg blown
off and he came home with scars both
physical and emotional and he did not
recover he spiraled downward and he
ultimately took his own life and that
battle didn't kill him but that war did
and look even in the humanitarian crisis
and I think we should be ready
congressman to intervene god forbid
there is a genocide but not without
congressional approval Democrats and
Republicans both in the Congress have
not challenged my answers you can
disagree with my please get away with
military without the congressional
approval we learned a lesson in Vietnam
we seem to have forgotten and decisions
put this to congressman Ryan today the
Taliban claimed responsibility for
killing two American servicemembers in
Afghanistan leaders as disparate as
President Obama and President Trump have
both said that they want to end US
involvement in Afghanistan but it isn't
over for America why isn't it over why
can't presidents of very different
parties and very different temperaments
get us out of there and how could you I
appreciate that question so I've been in
Congress 17 years and 12 of those years
I've sat on the Armed Services Committee
they're the Defense Appropriations
Committee or the Armed Services
Committee and the lesson that I've
learned over the years is that you have
to stay engaged in these situations
nobody likes it it's long it's tedious
but right now we have so I would say we
must be engaged in this we must have our
state department engaged we must have
our military engaged to the state to the
extent they need to be but the reality
of it is this president doesn't even
have people appointed in the State
Department to deal with these things
whether we're talking about Central
America whether we're talking about Iran
whether we're talking about Afghanistan
we've got to be completely engaged and
here's why because these flare-ups
distract us from the real problems in
the country if we're getting a drone
shot down for a hundred and thirty
million dollars because the president is
distracted that's a hundred and thirty
million dollars that we could be
spending in places like Youngstown Ohio
or Flint Michigan or rebuilding I'm
gonna give you 30 seconds actually to
jump up what he said arrived engage tell
the parents of those two soldiers who
were just killed in Afghanistan what we
just have to be engaged as a soldier I
will tell you that answer is
unacceptable we have to
- sighs enjoy please be honest Anwar we
have lost so many lives we've spent so
much money money that's coming out of
every one of our pockets money that
should be going into communities here at
home meeting the needs of the people
here at home we are no better off in
Afghanistan today than we were when this
war began this is why it's so important
to have a president and
commander-in-chief who knows the cost of
or who's ready to do the job on day one
I am ready to do that job when I walk
into the on the line here well you know
what you felt you felt like she was
refining you get 30 seconds I appreciate
that I hear what you're saying I would
just say I don't want to be engaged I
wish we were spending all this money in
places that I've represented that have
been completely forgotten and we were
rebuilding but the reality of it is that
the United States isn't engaged the
Taliban will grow and they won't have
bigger bolder terrorist acts we have got
to have some present there is this [ __ ]
out there long before we came in
thinking that we're going to somehow
squash this Taliban I didn't see them
when we weren't in there they started
flying planes into our buildings so I'm
just saying right now oh well this is a
lot of self-identity rise you should not
be protecting those people who are
plotting against us all I'm saying is if
we want to go in to elections and we
want to say that we gotta withdraw from
the world that's what President Trump is
saying we can I would love for us to I
think I'll kind of right now I want to
go down to Arabia I want to go down the
line here finish up foreign policy it's
a simple question what is art what is
the biggest threat to what is who is the
geopolitical threat to the United the
country here we go one more to answer
congressman Delaney can you repeat the
greatest in front of the United States
right now congressman Delaney
well the biggest geopolitical challenge
is
but they'll face geopolitical threat yes
remains nuclear weapons okay so those
are do you know that I got a different
question totally get it go ahead
governor Inslee the biggest threat to
the security the United States is Donald
Trump
[Applause]
the greatest threat that we face is the
fact that we are at a greater risk of
nuclear war today than ever before in
history Congress Congress senator
threats economic threat China but our
major threat right now is what's going
on in the Mideast with Iran if we don't
try to keep it at work or Leonard
slimmer than what we've been going here
one or two our existential threat is
climate change we have to confront it
before it's too late
senator Warner yeah senator Booker
nuclear proliferation and climate change
secretary Castro say China and climate
change at congressman Ryan knew China
without a question they're wiping us
around the world economically and mr.
Mir Russia because they're trying to
undermine our democracy and they've been
doing a pretty damn good job of that we
disagree with them but it keeps that
wide variety of answers and I mean that
no I mean that in a that's what this
debate is about this is the best part of
a debate like this congressman or work
special counsel Robert Muller's report
outlines multiple instances of potential
criminal behavior by President Trump
House speaker Pelosi is publicly and
privately resisted any move toward
impeachment in the house if the house
chooses not to impeach as president
would you do anything to address the
potential crimes that were outlined in
mr. Muller's reported yes and I'll tell
you why how well tell us what you would
do yeah that's the better I part of the
question one of the most powerful pieces
of art in the United States Capitol is
the Trumbull painting of General George
Washington resigning his commission to
the Continental Congress at the height
of his power submitting to the rule of
law in the will of people that has
withstood the test of time for the last
243 years if we set another precedent
now that a candidate who invited the
participation of a foreign power
a president who sought to obstruct the
investigation into the invasion of our
democracy if we allow him to get away
with this with complete impunity then we
will have set a new standard and that is
that an obstruction comes a position of
power and public trust that they hold
are above the law and we cannot allow
that to stand so we must begin
impeachment now so that we have the
facts and the truth and we follow them
as far as they go
and as high up as they reached and we
save this democracy and if we've not
been able to do that in this year or the
year that follows and under my
administration our Department of Justice
will pursue these facts and ensure that
there are account there are consequences
there's accountability issues that
Arsenal Rourke was just describing there
and the real political landscape in
which Nancy Pelosi is saying that
impeachment will not be pursued in the
house it raises the prospect and the
Moller report raises the prospect that
President Trump could be prosecuted for
some of those potential crimes down the
line no US president has ever been
prosecuted for crimes after leaving
office do you believe that President
Trump could or should be the first I
guess there's always a first I don't
think anyone's above the law I don't
think anyone is above the law including
a president I support speaker Pelosi's
decisions that she's making in the in
the House of Representatives pker I
think she knows more about the decision
as to whether and to impeach the
president than any of the 20/20
candidates combined conceded so me but I
do think you should i do think that no
one's above the law and this president
who is lawless should not be above the
law but I will tell you Rachel the one
thing when you're out doing has been
much campaigning as I've done four
hundred events all 99 counties in Iowa
this is not the number one issue the
American people ask us about it's not
maybe what we're gonna do for health
care how we're gonna lower
pharmaceutical prices how we're gonna
build infrastructure what we're gonna do
to create jobs in their communities you
know last year in our country eighty
percent of the money for start-up
businesses went to 50 counties in this
country there's over 3,000 counties in
this country that's what they care about
they care about fruits going on in the
public schools they care about what's
going on with jobs in their communities
with their pay with their health care
with infrastructure these are the issues
these kind of kitchen-table pocketbook
issues are actually what most Americans
care about
[Applause]
[Music]
and if we do not do something about
Russian interference in the election and
we let me check Connell stop all the
backup paper ballots then we're not
gonna get what we my got a sneaking it
but we blew through a break which is
good news to give you more time so I got
a sneak one in now more of this debate
let's pick it up here it continues right
after this yes I mean it's sort of off
the rails in a sense and I know there's
lots of people sending messages about
this that this is sort of taking a very
strange turn where everybody's just
talking over each other and it's getting
very very wacky so I mean we're gonna do
a broader analysis afterwards so let me
just thank some people because so many
people are signing up and doing great
things Scott Worthington signed up at
david pakman.com and karen simon
peterson is a new member rosboroughs a
patreon donation Kasper Martinez is a
new member Lea spear has signed up Tonya
tattoo has signed up Michael Gallagher
is a new member
Felicia mosses and you remember a lot of
people using that coupon code listed
right over down there
this is 2020 which saves you 40% the
show is funded by memberships these
extra streams are funded by memberships
and it's amazing to see all of these
great people Christopher Fernandez and
Marlin Martell
Felicia Moss I think I mentioned David
McCullough Shaq I hope is the right
pronunciation
Christopher Caballero and Chris Duffy
Adam Guthrie Jacob Larson Victor Ortiz
two new memberships for Adam Guthrie
interestingly enough maybe it's two
different Adam Guthrie's I don't know
Steven Hegel and Scott andrew has signed
up Salomon carpenter I believe I already
mentioned Christie Johnson and Daniel
hint Hilton and the super chats continue
to come in let's see if I can get to
just a couple constantine mattis says do
you think Biden will be playing a
central caret will be playing a
character tomorrow and flipping on
everything he said before or will he be
honest and be against Medicare and Pro
money and politics and all that I don't
know which Joe Biden is show
tomorrow but I will be here with you and
we can we can watch it together
Shelley Charlotte hair trying to send
$20.20 close enough thank you for
hosting thank you for watching Scott
Johnson says I despise you but
appreciate your voice respect alright
that's uh it's an interesting one um
let's see what else here
Rowdies forces just want to say love you
David keep up the good work a prim v85
says I love you more thank you
hood Atticus says on behalf of Andrew
Bella scene who wanted to contribute
thank you very much appreciate that
Joanna Apple says this is a meaningless
farce David we are in big trouble
Bernie 2020 we are just a few seconds
from getting back to the conclusion of
this debate I will also say thanks to
Martha's Inc who has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership taking
advantage of an even crazier coupon code
half 19 which isn't even on screen but
the coupon code half 19 will save you
50% that's a secret one
we're not publicizing that one widely
okay let's get back to this debate and
see how it rattles the first
presidential debate of the 2020 election
a two-night event Wednesday June 26 then
Thursday June 27 that Miami on NBC MSNBC
Telemundo and NBC News now
don't miss night 2 of the democratic
debate OS 10 more candidates battle it
out tomorrow at 9:00 Eastern two minutes
ago so this is the horrible doormat
practically disgusting
closing statements each candidate has 45
seconds we want to begin with former
congressman Delaney who will take three
minutes closing now closing okay 45
seconds we could make we could go on
we're in a mission to find the America
that's been lost lost through infighting
lost through inaction we're so much
better than this we're a country they
used to do things we saved the world we
created the American Dream from millions
of people like myself the grandson of
immigrants the son of a union
electrician who went on to become a
successful business leader and create
thousands of jobs but we did these
things with real solutions
not with impossible promises and those
are the roots that we have to get back
to I'm running for president to solve
these problems to build infrastructure
to fix our broken health care system to
invest in communities that have been
left behind to improve public education
I just don't want to be your president
to be don't be your president to do the
job thing is not about me this is about
getting America working again
thank you he will not be invited back
[Applause]
mayor your closing statement it matters
it matters in this fight for the heart
and soul of our party that we nominate a
candidate who has seen the face of
poverty and then just talk about it but
gave people $15 minimum wage it matters
that we nominate a candidate who saw the
destruction wrought by broken health
care system and gave people universal
health care it matters that we choose
someone who saw the wasted potential of
our children denied pre-k and gave it to
every single one of them for free these
things really matter and these are the
things that I've done in New York and I
want to do the same for this whole
country because putting working people
first
it matters we need to be that party
again let's work together with your help
we can put working people first again in
America thank you mayor de Blasio right
on time more spirited in 53 45 seconds
Bernie I have three grandchildren we
love them all and when I was thinking
about whether it run for president I
made a decision I decided that on my
last day on earth I wanted to look them
in the eye and tell him I did everything
humanly possible to protect them from
the ravages of the climate crisis and I
know to a moral certainty if we do not
have the next president who commits to
this as the top priority it won't get
done and I am the only candidate frankly
I'm surprised I'm the only candidate who
has made this commitment to make it the
top priority if you join me in that
recognition of how important this is we
can have a unified national mission we
can save ourselves we can save our
children we can save our grandchildren
and we can save literally the life on
this planet this is our moment honor
Thank You congressman but it is the
moment
there's nothing worse than not being
heard nothing worse than not being seen
and I know that because I've represented
for 17 years in Congress a forgotten
community they've tried to divide us
who's white who's black who's gay who's
straight who's a man who's a woman and
they ran away with all the gold because
they divided the working class it's time
for us to come together I don't know how
you feel but I'm ready to play some
offense I come from the middle of
industrial America but these problems
are all over our country there's a tent
city in LA there's homeless people and
people around our country who can't
afford a home it's time for us to get
back on track the teacher in Texas the
nurse in New Hampshire the waitress in
Wisconsin all of us coming together
playing offense with an agenda that
lifts everybody up think I will only
promise you one thing when I walk into
that Oval Office every morning you will
not be forgotten and your voice will be
heard thank you none back there but our
nation was founded on the principles of
Service Above Self people who fled Kings
who literally prospered on the backs and
the sacrifices of people coming here to
this country instead putting in place a
government that is of by and for the
people but that's not what we have
instead we have a government that is of
by and for the rich and powerful this
must end as president our white house
our white house will be a beacon of
light providing hope and opportunity
assuring in a new century where every
single person will be able to get the
health care they need where we will have
clean air to breathe and clean water to
drink where we will have good-paying
jobs in a new green economy join me in
ushering in this new century with peace
prosperity opportunity and justice for
all congresswoman thank you
this may llamo Julian Castro
yes toy Castellano poor Presidente de
los Estados Unidos the very fact that I
can say that tonight shows the progress
that we have made in this country like
many of you I know the promise of
America my grandmother came here when
she was seven years old as an immigrant
from Mexico and just two generations
later one of her grandsons is serving in
the United States Congress and the other
one is running for president of the
United States if I'm elected president I
will work hard every single day so that
you and your family can get good health
care your child can get a good education
and that you can have good job
opportunities whether you live in a big
city or a small town and on January 20th
2021 will say adios to Donald Trump best
one so far
[Applause]
things to know about me first I listen
to people and that's how I get things
done not her staff my I have at
Rutherford passing over a hundred bills
where I am the lead Democrat and that is
because I listened and I acted and I
think that's important in a president
everything else just melts away secondly
I'm someone that can win and beat Donald
Trump I have won every place every race
and every time I have won in the reddest
of districts one's at Donald Trump won
by over 20 points I can win in states
like Wisconsin and Iowa and in Michigan
and finally yeah I am NOT the
establishment party candidate I've got
respect but I'm not that person I am the
one that doesn't have a political
machine that doesn't come from money and
I don't make all the promises that
everyone up here makes but I can promise
you this I am going to govern with
integrity I'm going to have your back
and I'm gonna govern for you thank you
[Applause]
fifty years ago this month my family
moved into the town I grew up in because
after being denied a house because of
the color of their skin it was activists
mostly white activists they stood up and
fought for them that's the best of who
we are as America why would I got out of
law school I moved into the inner city
of Newark to fight as a tenant lawyer
for other people's rights I've taken on
bullies and beat them I've taken on
tough fights and we've won and we win
those fights not by showing the worst of
who we are but rising to who's best
Donald Trump wants us to fight him on
his turf and his terms we will beat him
I will beat him by calling this country
to a sense of common purpose again this
is a referendum on him and getting rid
of him but it's also a referendum on us
who we are and who we must be to each
other it's time we win this election and
that way I'll govern is by showing the
best of who we are because that's what
this country needs and deserves thank
you
- over
our daughter Molly turned 11 this week
I'm on this stage for her this country
entire team including song her same age
who've been separated from their parents
and are sleeping on concrete floors
under aluminum blankets tonight we're
gonna be there for them we're gonna
confront the challenges that we face we
can't return to the same old approach
we're gonna need a new kind of politics
one directed by the urgency of the next
generation those climate activists who
are fighting not just for their future
but for everyone's those students
marching not just for their lives but
for all of ours we'll need a movement
like the one that we led in Texas it
renewed our democracy by bringing
everyone in and writing nobody off
that's how we beat Donald Trump that's
how we bring this great country together
again join us this is our moment and the
generations that follow are counting on
us to meet at Thank You congressman
could've sworn I heard some things from
somewhere thank you it's a great honor
to be here never in a million years did
I think I would stand on a stage like
this I was born and raised in Oklahoma I
have three older brothers they all
joined the military I had a dream
growing up and my dream was to be a
public school teacher but a time I
graduated from high school my family my
family didn't have the money for a
college application
much less a chance for me to go to
college but I got my chance it was a $50
a semester commuter college that was a
little slice of government that created
some opportunity for a girl and it
opened my life I am in this fight
because I believe that we can make our
government we can make our economy we
can make our country work not just for
those at the top we can make it work for
everyone and I promise you this I will
fight for you as hard as I fight for my
own family
with us tonight and that will do it for
night one of this two night event and
guess what we've got ten more candidates
tomorrow night concludes our coverage of
this first democratic debate from Miami
for Savannah Jose Chuck and Rachel I'm
Lester Holt
all right so honestly one of the worst
debates that I've seen I mean some
people did well and we'll talk about it
tomorrow again I think it's Warren
Castro in de Blasio who did the best
there I'm not saying they're my favorite
candidates I'm not saying they're right
on all the issues but really I mean
listen this is not a format that is
great right I mean it's a minute to
answer 30-second rebuttal zahl on an ad
hoc basis not everybody gets to answer
every question it's too many candidates
and I think that you know part of the
problem is the format but part of the
problem is that you're pushed into a
format that's not ideal by the number of
candidates that are there so some of
them clearly are not going to last very
long hard to imagine Delaney and Tim
Ryan and and Inslee lasting too too much
longer and then there's a bunch of other
people on that stage who if they don't
really start doing significantly better
soon are going to have to go I mean Amy
Klobuchar she's got to start polling
more than whatever she's polling Tulsi
gabbard's got to start polling more than
whatever she's polling if she's going to
justify staying DeBlasio same thing so
there will be fewer people probably with
within I mean maybe by Monday a couple
of people will have dropped out I don't
know but night two will be a totally
different dynamic and I will hope to see
you back here again tomorrow evening
thanks for joining me tonight